and it's so like
especially when you're a regular and you
call in week by week and you don't get
any spots i don't know
were you ever there
was i ever went in the last 10 years
were you ever like months go by and you
didn't get a spot no yeah i've always
gotten spots yeah i couldn't imagine not
getting them yeah i think
i don't know what i would do i remember
when it switched from tommy to adam
the amount of times that you harassed
poor adam eager
because he wouldn't let you double dip
oh yeah um i mean poor guy what he what
kind of phone calls he has to field on
on a daily basis
i mean
it's probably the most thankless job
yeah it just got to be terrible
imagine being i would be great at it but
i know because you you're okay with
saying no to people yeah
i'm constantly telling i told emily a
couple weeks ago i used to tell adam all
the time just get me on the payroll as
assistant talent coordinator and i'll
handle just the negative calls
really i don't want to call anyone and
say here are your spots i don't call
anyone to say you know great job i just
want to call people and go
stop calling we don't have stage time
for you
let me ask you this okay let's say i'm
let's say my name is bruce mcpherson's
legend
it's legendary bruce physics you have
bruce mcvisions from corpus christi sure
right in the early 80s right brook
mcfizzens right yeah co-hosted the late
late late show yeah right which it was
on three in the morning yep he was after
tom snyder right after tom snyder right
rook bruce mcmahon
bruce mcfizzens what
what the worst fake name of all time
there's a vnz in it yeah
man he's [ __ ] foreign it's tough he's
from europe dude yeah he's from bruce
mcpherson he's scottish yeah and so he
you know signed with a big agency was on
a sitcom now it's rolling into the early
90s okay late 90s he's not getting that
much very still very funny on stage yeah
you have to call him to say you can't
perform ever again at the store yeah
you'll be able to do that yeah make the
call
ring ring bruce hey it's rick at the
comedy store hey rick
is that you yeah it's me man listen oh
my god
the other night when you're on stage
yeah listen hold on let me say something
right bruce i don't got time for this
today
i just want to say when you're on stage
yeah i thought oh you got this richard
bryan white guy very good yeah listen
we all agree i love you me and my family
love it when we break we when we break
none yeah we break down when you break
bread non-bread yeah i'm indian oh okay
from india
you can't tell i'm doing an indian
accent i thought it was good
he's from scotland too as well yeah okay
um
anyway so why you calling listen man i'm
calling cause it's been a hell of a run
man and you've a very good run yeah
you've done it
like the olympic and i just wanted to
let you know i think the laugh factory
is the place for you
we're done here
we don't have time for it anymore man no
one wants this this crazy corner act man
what about my bed take a cue from what
about my bit about bombay
[Music]
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
online therapy check out betterhelp.com
belly for 10 off of your first month
better help you guys um we've talked
about better help many many times
probably thousands of times yeah and
during the pandemic we um
did a lot of online therapy through
better